tu vois ce qui est très frappant dans
toutes les analyses du conflit alors je
suis très gêné très embêté parce que je
suis très décalé j'en suis conscient par
rapport à l'opinion commune des médias
et j'ai toujours peur d'avoir l'air
d'une brute insensible aux souffrances
du peuple crânien je suis parfaitement
conscient mais les gens ne voient pas
que désormais
la guerre fondamentalement n'est plus ou
n'a jamais été d'ailleurs une guerre
entre l'Ukraine et la Russie pour la
Russie l'Ukraine techniquement est un
problème mineur et prennent leur temps
il était en fait déjà très clair dans le
camp Poutine a annoncé
ce que moi j'appelle une invasion et non
pas une opération militaire spéciale
c'était un défi à l'OTAN et aux
États-Unis et pas simplement à l'Ukraine
et la
nous sommes suffisamment forts pour
rectifier mettons nos frontières ou
l'objectif
je dirais que pour le moment l'objectif
n'a pas été atteint mais je voudrais
vraiment
dire que il y a un autre objectif
beaucoup plus important qui a été
atteint c'est que les
Occidentaux qui ont mon sens sont je dis
comme merci on provoqué cette guerre
pensait vraiment
l'agresseur c'est quand même
c'est pas c'est pas important je veux
dire je peux pas
répondu à ces questions c'est pour ça
que j'ai dit je pense commercial comme
une certaine école donc je répète je
répète l'argument pour montrer que je ne
me pas je répète l'argument de
versaillesur c'est
la Russie avait annoncé qu'elle ne
tolérerait pas une ukrainement de l'OTAN
l'Ukraine était défacto membres de
l'OTAN parce que son armée était
organisée par les Américains les Anglais
et les Polonais et la Russie a fait une
guerre préventive ou fait une guerre de
son point de vue préventive moi
j'accepte ça je n'aime pas la guerre et
j'accepte ça mais pour moi ce que je
voulais dire ce qui est très important
c'est que je crois que les les
Américains ont plus ou moins étaient
dans la situation de provocateur donc
provoquant c'est-à-dire poussant les
Russes les adossants et les forces en ça
mais parce qu'ils avaient les
néoconservateurs américains
travaillaient avec l'hypothèse que la
mécanique des sanctions allait détruire
la Russie
les Russes pensaient suffisamment fort
pour résister à vos sanctions mais ce
qui s'est passé et
à faire autre chose c'est que la Russie
a beaucoup mieux
résistants qu'on imaginait sa croissance
reprend et en revanche on est en train
de constater les sociétés occidentales
néolibérales et qui ont fait toutes les
bonnes réformes qui valaient etc sont en
train de constater qu'elles n'ont plus
l'appareil industriel pour fournir des
obus à l'Ukraine et maintenant l'enjeu
les gens disent les gens disent les gens
disent il ne faut pas humilier pour
utile enfin les gens sont dans une sorte
de rêve mais la vérité c'est que
maintenant à mon avis depuis que la
Chine a compris que la Russie avait de
large chance de s'en sortir et est en
train d'entrer dans le jeu avec sa base
industrielle c'est l'OTAN qu'il s'agit
d'abattre pour les Russes maintenant les
gens n'ont pas compris le niveau des
enjeux on va y revenir ce qui est très
intéressant dans votre point de vue sur
le conflit ukrainien c'est que vous
dites est-ce que vous disiez Alexandre
devecchio tout le monde s'est trompé a
commencé dans les Russes mais aussi ceux
qui ont cru qu'ils avaient une armée
forte et une économie faible et vous
dites c'est l'inverse oui alors question
bien internaute justement aux
commentaires à votre interview est-ce
que vous pensez pas quand même que la
valeur du rouble n'est pas aujourd'hui
sur estimée qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
vous voyez c'est ça le problème c'est
que c'est le
quand je parle d'une guerre qui nous
mène à la vérité donc on commence on
part dans cette guerre et on mesure dit
c'est ce que les occidentaux avaient en
tête le PIB produit un terror brut russe
c'est 3% du PIB occidental d'accord et
donc comment est-ce que cette économie
pourrait tenir mais une fois qu'on a vu
que le PIB ne représente ça va être des
avocats sur paix aux États-Unis des
médecins sur payés avec d'ailleurs une
mentalité
qui augmente et si en Russie il y a une
capacité de production industrielle
agricole qui est en ascension rapide ce
qu'on aura au final c'est plus des
chiffres des choses financières c'est
des capacités de production c'est ça la
guerre et en ce sens cette guerre
devient un immense test de vérité sur je
dirais
le résultat du néolibéralisme on
attendait un effondrement la Russie
c'est l'Angleterre qui est en train de
s'effondrer c'est quand même surprenant
alors est-ce que c'est c'est pas lié
forcément à la guerre en Ukraine
c'est-à-dire que la guerre en Ukraine
les opposants au brexit disent que c'est
lié au brexit je sais qu'on doit dire ça
c'est clair alors là par contre je suis
tout à fait prêt à reconnaître une
erreur sur le brexit moi j'étais je
pensais que le brexit pouvait bien se
passer j'étais plutôt pour j'admets que
j'avais pas du tout
anticipé ou compris les motivations des
conservateurs anglais je n'avais surtout
pas pris conscience du degré
d'insuffisance de la base industrielle
des etc mais la vérité de la situation
de l'Angleterre actuelle ce qui est pour
moi un drame personnel l'Angleterre est
un pays que d'habitude je ne critique
jamais ça fait 50 ans que je me trompe
sur l'Angleterre je suis en train de
m'excuser de l'avoir fait peut-être que
les Anglais vont remonter si vous
voulez la destruction d'un appareil
industriel c'est un processus de très
très longue durée et ça va même
commencer en fait avant tatcheur mais
c'était dramatisé par et les gens vont
dire que c'est l'échec du brexit mais la
vérité c'est que c'est l'échec du
néolibéralisme et que la capacité des
Américains les Américains n'ont pas fait
le brexit
eux non plus n'arrivent plus à produire
des armements en quantité suffisante
comment vous définissez le peut-être on
n'est pas tout à fait sûr pour les
États-Unis comment vous définissez le
néolibéralisme pas le
néolibéralisme c'est cette espèce de de
détestation de l'état de de dénonciation
de l'État en tant que déresponsabiliser
des responsabilisants les citoyens
rendant
inefficaces
paralysant la société et insistant pour
l'établissement partout de concurrence
pure et parfaite sur des marchés ou
situation dans lequel le marché lui-même
devient un instrument de discipline plus
terribles que l'État d'avant et cette et
avec cette idée le truc de
thatchering à ce site la société ça
n'existe pas c'est qu'il y a que des
individurations sur un marché il n'y a
pas de croyance collective de société
qui permet aux gens d'agir ensemble et
ce qu'on est en train de mesurer c'est
que la puissance de l'Amérique a été
dévastée par sa propre idéologie et que
quand à l'Angleterre mais j'ai envie de
pleurer quand j'y pense votre on va
revenir sur sur la guerre en Ukraine et
justement sur sur les Chinois d'abord
votre plan de paix sur votre point de
vue sur le plan de pêche chinois vous
disiez le 4 février dans un entretien
vidéo pour Olivier Berruyer à la minute
ou les Américains diront que la Chine
aide la Russie le monde entier sera que
les États-Unis ont perdu la guerre
qu'est-ce qu'il vous fait avoir cette
intuition et est-ce qu'elle est dansait
déjà confiance alors d'abord le plan de
pêche chinois les gens sont très déçus
par le plan de paix chinois
mais en fait des Chinois n'ont jamais
dit qu'il avait un plan de paix je sais
qu'après la conférence de Munich toute
la presse occidentale qui est un peu
affolée en ce moment il y a un véritable
affolement il a dit oui les Chinois vont
présenter un plan de paiement c'est un
truc de position etc et ce qui affole
les gens c'était de voir la Chine sortir
de son rôle d'observateur distant et
commencer d'occuper sa véritable place
dans le système mondial et donc
critiquer pour pas l'atelier d'ailleurs
comment on l'a souvent critiqué moi je
pense que ce qui se passe actuellement
mais ça n'est pas vrai simplement pour
la Chine c'est qu'au début tout le monde
a été un peu
honnêtement la guerre nous a tous mis
dans un état de stupéfaction c'est
vraiment c'est un vrai choc pour tout le
monde pour les ruisseaux forts
pour les gens comme moi qui ne pensent
qu'à se battre pour le plus réaliste de
l'opinion dans son propre pays c'est
pour ça que et au début on était bah on
attendait comme vous l'avez rappelé
des performances militaires
extraordinaires de l'armée russe qui ne
sont pas arrivés première surprise et
puis un effondrement d'économie russe
qui n'est pas non plus arrivé et ce qui
s'est passé pour moi sur le plan
économique permet la Russie s'installer
dans la guerre et beaucoup plus
important et le monde entier donc les
Russes prennent confiance
c'est pas du je pense pas du tout qu'ils
ont intérêt à arrêter la guerre
personnellement et surtout le monde se
rend compte que s'engager du côté des
Russes c'est beaucoup moins dangereux
qu'il n'imaginait c'est à dire que il y
a un effet de ralliement de l'ensemble
du camp antioxydantal derrière le Russe
maintenant qu'ils avaient fait la preuve
qui pouvait tenir le coup c'est ça que
le véritable alors la Chine si vous
voulez le problème c'est que la guerre
la guerre d'attrition
c'est des morts il y a la tricion en
termes de pertes donc là les Russes sont
très économes ils font très attention
contrairement à ce qu'on dit parce que
la Russie a un vrai problème
démographique et on vit dans cinq ans
ils pourront plus faire ça de guerre
parce qu'ils vont avoir des classes
creuses je dirais que les Chinois aussi
vont avoir des problèmes de classe
creuses dans un certain temps et puis il
y a l'attrition sur le plan industriel
et là
partez de la deuxième guerre mondiale
que c'était quoi la force de l'Amérique
et la force du grand c'est que
l'industrie américaine un deuxième
guerre mondiale c'était la moitié de la
production industrielle mondiale donc à
partir du moment où les États-Unis sont
en train en guerre c'était terminé les
Allemands avaient perdu et là vous
prenez la production de la chimie dans
le monde la Chine c'est 30 % des
machines outils le Japon 15 l'Allemagne
14 ou 15 et l'Amérique se bat pour la
quatrième place avec l'Italie à 7 ou 8%,
c'est à dire que l'Amérique n'a plus la
base industrielle
comment alors que ça a été une puissance
industrielle oui mais c'est ce qui est
arrivé à l'industrie française donc à
partir du moment où on se dit que la
Chine pourrait devenir
l'arsenal des autocraties comme
l'Amérique a été l'arsenal démocratie on
voit où on va est-ce que comme les votes
Michel de gegey le directeur du Figaro
Histoire dans son dernier livre la
mélancolie d'Athéna les deux puissances
ne sont pas dans le paradoxe de tussidie
et est-ce que et que le vainqueur soit
les Russes soit les Américains ce sera
de toute façon une victoire à la Pyrrhus
et un affoli un affaiblissement du bloc
Occident Russie au profit de la Chine
non ça va je pense qu'on va tous être
perdant dans cette histoire c'est à dire
que si vous prenez les deux guerres
mondiales vraiment sanglants la première
et la deuxième ça se passait dans une
paire de l'histoire où toutes les
populations étaient en croissance rapide
sur les la croissance de la France qui
croient c'est lentement parce qu'elle
avait eu une baisse de fécondité un
siècle avant tous les autres mais les
populations anglaises allemandes russes
encore plus augmentaient japonaise etc
et ça permet d'expliquer pourquoi les
comment dire les ces pays après des
guerres qui avaient fait des millions de
morts des hécatomes
jardin Stalingrad enfin c'était des
boucheries des vrais pas comme une
échelle incommensurable par rapport à ce
qui se passe à ma route en ce moment
mais après la guerre deuxième guerre
mondiale après demi siècle d'épuisement
bah tous ces pays ont été capables de
faire des trentes glorieuses d'un genre
ou d'un autre là alors ce qu'il y a mené
à la guerre c'était que les pays
progressaient des vitesses différentes
et se faisait peur donc l'Angleterre
avait peur des Allemands les Allemands
avaient peur des Russes et donc c'est
déséquilibres mena l'attiduellement donc
il faut qu'on se débarrasse des Russes
et des Français avant qu'ils soient trop
tard les angles on doit se débarrasser
de la flotte allemande un truc comme ça
maintenant on a un paradoxe c'est-à-dire
que c'est vrai que les rapports de force
entre les nations évolue très vite sans
avoir industrielle mais dans un contexte
de dépression démographique c'est à dire
que toutes les rapports de force
changent mais la plupart des populations
des pays avancés vont diminuer sauf
celle des États-Unis qui continuent à
augmenter mais qui sont remplies de
consommateurs plutôt que de producteurs
donc quand ça sera fini tout le monde
sera perdant et tout le monde sera
épuisé ça serait ça la bonne raison de
discuter de s'entendre est-ce que
la grande faiblesse de l'Occident
finalement ne tient pas
dans la faiblesse j'aperçois votre
réponse de ce concept qui vous est cher
c'est à dire les structures familiales
non mais oui c'est-à-dire qu'on voit ça
ça marche tout de suite frapper quand
j'ai vu les cartes des votes à l'ONU les
gens qui qui nous soutenaient pas les
Occidentaux c'est à quel point
l'Occident c'était juste l'Europe les
états l'anglosphère l'Angleterre Canada
États-Unis
et puis le Japon et la Corée c'est un
tout petit monde le monde
je veux dire qui pour moi anthropologue
est un monde très particulier c'est un
monde traditionnellement assez féministe
contrairement certains pensent le
féminisme ou la situation élevée des
femmes est anciens individualisme pris
dans des évolutions sociétales que
j'approuve en gros et qui ne gêne pas
puisque je suis un Occidental on va se
raconter qu'on est autre chose que ce
qu'on est en fait et puis mais
75% du monde au centre des pays comme la
Russie la Chine le monde arabe c'est ce
qu'un anthropologue décrirait comme des
cultures patrilinaires centrées sur les
hommes avec beaucoup plus de sentiments
communautaire dans la famille et dans
les systèmes nationaux et donc et
l'Afrique aussi une bonne la plus grande
partie de l'Afrique et l'Occident n'a
pas
compris que que cette guerre dans cette
guerre
beaucoup de sensibilité
conservatrice
antioxydantal etc du monde pouvait
beaucoup plus facilement s'identifier à
la Russie conservatrice et autoritaire
de Poutine plutôt qu'au fantaisie
culturel du monde occidental et pourtant
l'Occident soutient un peuple l'Ukraine
et qui a fait l'admiration de tous par
justement sa résilience et ça
mobilisation et est-ce qu'on n'a pas
sous-estimé ces forces là et par la même
la force du sentiment national alors ça
ça a été je dirais la grande surprise et
la grosse erreur de Poutine c'est à dire
que à la veille de la guerre d'Ukraine
l'Ukraine était décrite pas du tout
comme une démocratie naissante mais
comme ce qu'on appelle la firstate
de la corruption des oligarques une
diminution de population de 10 ou 15
millions d'habitants en fait une société
en perdition et ce que les Russes n'ont
pas été capables d'imaginer ce que je
n'ai pas été capable d'imaginer c'est
qu'une société comme ça
aider financièrement et techniquement
par l'Occident pouvait trouver dans la
guerre un espoir une façon d'exister OK
et c'est pour ça qu'on est quand on
quand on est confronté à ce qui se passe
en Ukraine moi personnellement je suis
toujours partagé
entre un sentiment d'admiration parce
que c'est vrai que ce qui est fait pour
l'écran est admirable mais avec une
inquiétude sur une certaine dimension
nihiliste voyez moi la thématique du
néodasisme ukrainien je suis pas trop là
dedans par contre
l'idée du d'un nihilisme c'est d'une
fascination de la mort ou d'une capacité
de sacrifice ça c'est un vrai problème
et d'ailleurs c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut intégrer quand on étudie les
stratégies militaires ukrainiennes qui
en fait sont très coûteuses en âme on
dit toujours les Russes sacrifient des
tas d'hommes et en fait la réalité sur
le terrain c'est l'inverse c'est
l'Ukraine qui sacrifie d'État
[Musique]